so i managed to escape the office today
and i brought you down to the river here
this is the river cam in cambridge and i
brought you down to the river because i
want to talk about pie so what does pie
have to do with rivers
let me show you so let me draw an
approximation of the river cam here or
any river in fact
here is my picture there you go of a
river
what does this have to do with pie well
we can measure how bendy this river is
how much it meanders by taking the
length of the river that's the whole
length which we might call
capital l
and we divide that
by the direct root there we go as the
crow flies that directs roots well it's
going to be much quicker we're going to
call that
little l so we're going to divide by
little l that figure is called sinuosity
so we'll call that s for sinuosity it's
a measure of how bendy the river is
so if the river was completely straight
then it would have a sinuocity of one
or if it was really bendy it would have
a high sinuocity there's no limit to how
high sinuocity can be
but there are some people who figured
out that well in theory
the average cinerosity of rivers should
be
pi
so we took the river cam here and we
looked at its total length
which could be
i don't know 10 miles
divided up by the direct route
then we should get something like
3.14 now it might be bigger than that it
might be smaller than that but we look
at all the rivers in the world the
average should be about 3.14 so the
length of a river is just over three
times longer than the direct route
how did these guys justify this well
this was published in a paper in science
in the 90s they were actually trying to
model rivers and how they meander and
bend they used fluid dynamics to model
the flow of a river and sometimes the
they became very bendy and the behavior
became very chaotic and then suddenly
all the rivers became straight again
because they would form something that
is known as oxbow lakes
so if i have a river here
if it becomes very very bendy like this
then
what can happen is the water will find
a shortcut it will go across this you
will cut off this large bend
and this forms an oxbow lake so this
will dry out and it is no longer part of
the river the river becomes more
straight by forming this oxbow lake so
it becomes straighter so they found that
the
highest sinuocity tended to be around
3.5 so it didn't just go unlimitedly
large so high seniorities were about 3.5
low sinuocities were about 2.7
so not all the way down to one and it
would tend to sort of meander between
those two values so it's the formation
of these oxbow lakes that
control the sinuosity
of a river now how is this meandering
caused
well as the water flows through the
river
uh on the outside of the bend it starts
to erode
here so it becomes more bendy on the
inside of the curve it starts to deposit
soil
and this is how you form the bends but
these oxbow lakes then cut off
the bends
they did try and justify they tried to
justify that figure pie in the footnotes
it was footnote 14 of the paper and to
justify it they went to fractal geometry
and they said well the curves of a river
are like arcs of a circle
and the little wiggles of a river
they're like little arcs of circles and
if you add up all these arcs together
then the sinuosity you get should be
around about pie i did wonder for a long
time this was internet folklore i did
have to look at the paper to see who was
justified they are using a model here so
it was a fluid dynamics model they
invoked this fractal geometry to justify
this pie figure
the rivers they're modeling was
unrestricted by geography
in real life
would you get this figure well the
theory says we should
but in real life do we that's an
interesting question but i mean the
world's really well mapped now has no
one checked this has no one fed in the
amazon and the nile and said well what's
the reality i've tried to find the data
i've looked for the data i've tried to
find it i couldn't find a nice set of
data
i think i found a paper about rivers in
norway but i couldn't get access to it
so i did try for you i did try and find
out so if anyone wants to have a look at
the sinuocity of their local river and
see if it's anywhere near pie that would
be interesting it may not be near pie
because this is an average we're talking
about
it could be
hugely meandering it could have a huge
seniority it could be very straight
we need to get all the rivers in the
world and have a look at their
data plus
we do have restrictions in real life
rather than using pi so the entire thing
is going to be pi based
we get the circumference an exact number
of pies give or take
can you do that again and this time talk
me through it as you do
you ask a lot brady i'll i'll try so
three one four one five
nine bend up to nine back to two
and then we've got